bon alors les habiles voler les frères
c'est dans la rue en pose des questions
aux gens pendant qu'ils nous répondent
on s'habille exactement comme c'est
parti inédit qu'est ce que vous pensez
des transports en commun parisiens est
très adapté beaucoup beaucoup de métro
beaucoup de bus
donc voilà non c'est sont vraiment
vraiment bien et votre chat on pense
quoi salut salut ça va super c'est quoi
la c'est la télévision sa division et on
en a marre de la télé bande de francs
maçons de merde c'est la conspiration il
n'y a jamais eu d'icebergs le titanic
c'était un rocher suchard le
réchauffement climatique laps de temps
qui fait se passe de combat si mlle il
transpire comme un goret film le salut
macron c'est un robot qu'est ce que vous
pensez des transports en commun
parisiens mais ça peut être assez sympa
mais en règle générale c'est pas du tout
mis à jour le rer c où il est là où il
n'est pas là aussi on se rend compte
qu'au final ils sont sept là mais il
vient pas et autres bons choix
ma soeur gpat hier j'ai pas le temps
maintenant l'année finir si c'est toi
qui est trop belle toile plus belle plus
en plus un vrai mais toi tu es plus
deuil plus maintenant tenter l'infini
plus en ils se sont beaucoup améliorées
en propreté ces dernières années
après c'est vrai que on est on n'est pas
tout seul a pas risquent à huile très
dense
et votre elle en pense quoi merci
d'accord ah ouais parfait mercer dehors
des phares de giroud à la donc le
mariage a lieu baoji rituel venez
nombreux voilà on est content on vous
invite tous au vin d'honneur
salut tout le monde le frère de gilles
verdez n'ont pas ni touche c'est un
imposteur
est ce que vous pensez des transports en
commun parisiens globalement ça va je
pense que on n'est pas trop pas trop mal
et votre elle en pense quoi
mon frère
tu penses quoi on est essentiellement
avec le canasson jeu belle de coeur dans
la cinquième à longchamp je vous en dis
pas plus on a un plan
on voit du côté de moi j'habite au nord
de paris je suis dans le missouri donc
c'est pas pour autant séduit et jamais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]